Mark Steyn is an author and columnist he
guest hosted this program for three days
last week Ann did a great job and we're
happy to have him back so mark you saw
the video those just you know those are
anti hate groups the ones screaming and
throwing things yeah and actually
threatening to kill people and wearing
masks and in fact having as you said
having all the attributes not of
anti-fascists but of fascists and I'm
one of those people because when you
look at the men you see like the little
dweeby pajama boy types talking about
wanting to kill people and it's easy to
laugh it off and say that they don't
really mean it they're not into it but
in fact when you look at what has been
going on the increase in the level of
targeted intimidation of people who just
happen to have a political disagreement
with them I think we are approaching the
point at which someone is going to get
killed over this and the media will play
a large part in that because when they
say that thugs on the street
intimidating not not just political
targets but Jen just general passing a
motor vehicle traffic the the the media
like CNN who called them anti hate
groups are actually a big part of the
problem here the sentimental ization and
glamorization of violence of course but
you can understand why the crowd is in a
frenzy because they believe what they've
been told which is there is a massive
white supremacist fascist movement on
the verge of taking over and I guess my
question is where are these people I've
lived in this country from 49 years I'm
not familiar with any large group that
believes that I never run into anyone
who thinks that I don't know a single
person who believes that this is a
fantasy it's a lie why do the rest of us
go along with it and I go yeah it's a
real problem really where what I'm
talking about well I'm totally
completely oh you're you're wrong there
Tucker there are 17 white supremacists
in America they're living in their
parents basement because nothing makes
you feel more supremacist than living in
your parents basement and some
the media has presented this as a as a
nationwide phenomenon but it's important
to understand why they've done that
they've done that as part of a strategy
to deal Aegina mais people not people
who are white supremacist but people who
are ever so teensy-weensy li
right-of-center
so it's part of a campaign to to to
denormalize the Republican Party and
it's also by the way where restrictions
on free speech a lead so when you have
all this denormalization and deep
platforming at American colleges where
you say oh we can't have this guy come
and speak to us because he happens to
believe that America should have tighter
immigration controls you eventually end
up with people who are incapable of
making any argument and can only punch
you in the face because the alternative
to free speech is just to blow things up
and smash stuff and that's what you see
on the streets it does seem like we're
all kind of complicit in this though I
mean I never hear anybody say wait wait
I reject the premise of your argument
everything you're saying is nuts nobody
ever says it like oh yeah well it's too
now it's like one side is absolutely
bent on preventing me from saying what I
think is true and the other side is kind
of passive it's not parody it's not
close from what I can tell no no no and
I think that's where we we don't push
back on it hard enough I mean I think I
think frankly you know it's it's it's a
seduction when you have comedians for
example standing up waving the severed
head of a president that comedian
doesn't want to actually sever the head
of the president that's a bit too much
hard work for but you can see she's
turned on by it and there are other
people who were turned on by it and
among all those people maybe there is
one who is sufficiently turned on by it
not necessarily because you can't it's
hard to get close to the president but
you may run into you know the assistant
deputy undersecretary of whatever from
the White House that you happen to have
seen on TV when she's in an Applebee's
or a
99s or whatever and you might beat her
up I mean that's actually and Maxine
Waters would encourage you to do that so
we have people who are essentially on
the same continuum as the Charlie Hebdo
killers where they think the answer to a
DISA those guys who killed the Charlie
had they were witty amusing intellectual
people killed by guys who don't know
anything except how to kick the door
down and kill you and and that's
actually these guys in anti-fur are the
same thing they can't make an argument
they're morons but they're morons who
have the scent of blood in their
nostrils when you give up on speech you
wind up with violence that is exactly
right that is a very deep point thank
you